[Music]
the election was on tuesday and as of
right now
when we are taping this show it seems
like
former vice president joe biden is on
track to win
but it was too close to call all week
and because of that we had to prepare
two completely different shows
one in case biden won and one in case
trump won
and look we worked too damn hard to just
throw one away at the very last minute
so tonight instead of doing a monologue
i'm just gonna give you both of them
well guys joe biden is our new president
soon trump will be out of office resign
to a life of screaming about people on
twitter
basically the same thing he was doing
before but with less of a chance of
killing people
hooray well guys
donald trump is still the president
what the
this happened because of you every
single one of you
and it's proof that democracy can work
this happened because of you every
single
one of you and it's proof that our
democracy is a sham
and that god is dead
america is the greatest country in the
world
and when i walked into that voting booth
on tuesday
i did it with pride and i do it again
because that's how much i believe in us
you mother made me get up early as hell
on a tuesday morning for this
i had to be dragged out of bed i was
tricked into going there
because someone told me that jill scott
was doing a pop-up concert at the
elementary school
only for me to get there and be all like
where's jill
where's jill am i late like a damn fool
you made a fool of me
i had a feeling that joe biden was gonna
win
[Music]
i knew this [ __ ] was gonna happen
because at the end of the day there are
more americans who care about each other
and
about this country it was the damn white
women again wasn't it
wasn't it white women will be the death
of me
nothing makes me feel the united in
united states
more than knowing that this country
recognizes a fascist
when it sees one and now he's gone
because that's what we wanted
y'all wanted this we went through four
years with this man
and then had a global pandemic keep us
all indoors for over
half of the year in fear of a deadly
sickness
which he ended up getting himself and
then you said
let's do all that again i am done with
this damn country
all right so now you've seen both
segments and
the way things are going we hope the
right one is
unless trump pulls some last-minute
shady [ __ ] with the supreme court and
then it's going to be all
and that was the two shows we prepared
tarik
which one of those shows was better i
don't know the votes are still being
tabulated we should have the results in
two to four days
it's too many it's too many you should
really you should know right now i'm
sorry
you're you have the only vote i well i
still i'm an
undecided voter i don't know really what
to i really
don't see how they're they're plus and
minuses to both all right
they're kind of the same no oh gross
yeah whoever that guy is
you're absolutely right well while tarik
is counting votes i want to talk for a
second about a conversation i had this
week
these election results were way closer
than i wanted them to be
i wanted trump to lose by a bajillion d
vote so i could feel good about my
fellow americans and
know that they overwhelmingly reject
racism and racist ideology
that didn't happen and i feel sad about
that but
as the results rolled in this week
little by little it started to look like
biden was going to win and that trump
would be out of office soon and
that's one thing i could feel good about
i was thinking about that when i got a
call from my sister lacey who lives in
nebraska
i told her i was starting to feel a
little optimistic
and she said that's because you live in
new york you're in the land of the free
meanwhile i'm in nebraska voting to
abolish slavery
and i laughed and laughed because i
thought lacey was exaggerating
and then she said no i'm serious
which brings us to a segment called
you all just left it like that
it turns out that in 1875 after the u.s
government abolished slavery
nebraska added an amendment to their
constitution
that allows slavery or involuntary
servitude as punishment for a crime
so you guys added that to your
constitution in 1875 and then
y'all just left it like that meaning
that in the present day that we're all
currently living in if you were
convicted of a crime in nebraska it
would be legal for you to be forced into
slavery and
yeah y'all just left it like that
at no point in the last 145 years did
someone look at a nebraska constitution
and think
hey maybe we need to proofread that you
know to just see if there's anything
crazy in there
y'all just left it like that so this
week
grown black men and women had to go to
the polls and look
slavery itself in the eye and call it
bad
in america in the year 2020
y'all just left it like that slavery got
abolished
you created a slavery loophole and then
145 years later people had to go to the
polls to reabolish slavery oh my god
oh wait hold the phone it did get
abolished right
the amendment ultimately passed and the
wording
will be removed oh thank god
it's finally fixed because i was about
to be
all like y'all just left it like that
now before election day when we were
planning this show
we were feeling hopeful about joe
biden's chances we looked at the polls
and we read the news and we started to
believe that he was gonna win
so we went out and we bought a bunch of
confetti cannons and
we were gonna shoot them off in this
week's episode to celebrate
as of this taping though we still don't
officially
officially know that he will win
but i have all these confetti cannons
and
it turns out they have an expiration
date on them
they expire this weekend and there is a
clause in my contract that says
i am not allowed to under any
circumstances
waste props i should have read that
contract more clear
more carefully so instead of shooting
them off
during a celebration about biden winning
i'm going to shoot them
off while i talk about where we are
right now in this segment called
where we are right now
[Music]
despite the fact that all votes have not
been counted
and despite the fact that all
projections have him on track to lose
donald trump appeared in public this
week and declared victory
i'm sorry i know that isn't an
appropriate use of these i just
my hands are tied i have no choice trump
declaring victory is insane
even more insane he has filed a lawsuit
to stop the counting of votes in
pennsylvania
which would disenfranchise thousands of
voters
again i'm sorry my hands are tied i
can't help it
and on thursday trump's supporters
stormed locations where votes were being
counted
and chanted stopped the count
interfering with the election process
and intimidating poll workers
these actions are undermining democracy
they're threatening the integrity of
this election
and they're threatening the integrity of
every election that comes after it
yep sorry i'm sorry i'm smiling it's the
confetti
tarik what do you think i think
i'm not sure if our country will ever
bounce back from this
and i think that in the future you
should try
to read your contracts more carefully
those are both good points in conclusion
we can't celebrate today
because we still don't know what the
future holds for america
but i do know that if biden wins i'ma be
all like
[Music]
baby
[Music]
[Applause]
you